du cimetière musulman à la mairie la rue
Marius et Harry Leblond traversent
Saint-Paul calme et résidentiel au
départ elle s'anime à mesure qu'on
s'approche de sa partie
commerçante une rue pluriel donc mais
tout cela a-t-il quelque chose à voir
avec Marius et Harry
Leblond qui étaai Marius et Harry
Leblond bonne question ça fait longtemps
que j'ai pas regardé les livres un
écrivain ou je sais pas c'est un quoi un
pot un poète pote le blond c'était son
frère je pense c'était deux cousins
origina de Saint-Paul ou il sont partis
sur Paris il a reçu un Prix de la
critique littéraire et je crois qu'il
été trois fois couronn
gagéo
les cousins Georg Athénas et aé Merlot
alias Marius et Harry Leblond ont vécu
ensemble une aventure littéraire hors du
commun George est né à Saint-Denis en
1977 et mé en 1880 à
Saint-Pierre très jeune l'aîné initie
son protégé à la
littérature le prier aime une Marie
blonde il deviendra Marius
Leblond le second est amoureux
d'Henriette il se nommera
Harry un pseudo pour éviter les
désagréments à leurs
parents c'est à Paris en 1902 que paraît
leur première œuvre les Vies parallèles
dès lors ils sont prolixes plus de 200
titres publiés dans la Revue de Paris et
la Revue des Deux Mondes ou encore dans
la Revue
blanche ils rafleront de multiples prix
dont celui de l'Académie française et le
goncour pour en France
en 1911 il lance le musée léonerx et
lors de leur tournée à la Réunion et à
l'île Maurice en 1930 il rencontre un
véritable
triomphe en mai 1953 Marius qui avait si
souvent soigner son cousin à la santé
fragile succombe à une congestion
pulmonaire 5 ans plus tard c'est dans
l'anonymat que Meur
Harry tous deux reposent au cimetière de
vogirard